one candidate however was really
sticking up for Trump that would be my
pal it's a fake ramaswami we have sent
this letter and I'm happy to announce
this is my commitment
on January 20th 2025. if I'm elected the
next U.S president
pardon Donald J Trump for these offenses
in this federal case and I have
challenged I have demanded that every
other candidate in this race either
signed this commitment to Pardon on
January 20th 2025 or else to explain why
they are not love it great stuff
obviously the other candidates should
promise to Pardon Donald Trump if it
comes to that if Trump is sent to prison
and if these guys win the nomination and
if one of these guys becomes president
yeah of course they should pardon Trump
of course